me
g
so we are here in the heart of the
new garden at roland garros which
hosts the sculptures of the four
musketeers sculptures which were
made by the artist quickly with your
genius
so it's important for the history of
tennis
it's important  for you it is important
for all the young people
his sculptures that you see there embodies
the history of the stadium and it is very
important not to forget the
victories that I propose to you is
that we go and find out why this stadium is
call roland garros
in double
[Music]
we are in front of this magnificent
sculpture and I wanted to thank and
congratulate caroline brisset who is there
who is a young artist who has produced
this extraordinary work in a
very poetic tribute that you come in
hero who now welcomes everyone here
visitors to vienna at roland garros
pass in front of this this gentleman this
historical roland-garros writing at
mandeure an end to these two worlds
will come out tisane espa  gnole against the
narration and that the file he knows that
the national road
[Music]
welcome to roland garros rafa you are
since 2005 a player whose name is
attached to that of the roland garros tournament
you write you continue to write
superbly beautiful pages  of
the history of the tournament and of your history
your compatriot jordi dies fernandez who
is with us today whom I greet
and whom I thank and congratulate knew how to
grasp and you will discover it in a
moment in this representation
the prodigious players that you  es
[Music]
[Applause]
good
[Music]
global mask special
world tennis
there is a sculptor com - stan smyl
karoutchi simon relative friend will be for the
canary skyscraper in form than
in terror in the face of the press for
help
we know that canada is very
distressed
the nagging fatigue humanity
[Music]